いきなりですが、引っ越します。
よだれが出たよ
かなり早いでしょ
YouTuberが、こんなに早く引っ越す人が他にいるか？
いや、いない
俺が最速だ(ﾄﾞﾔｧ
まぁ、とりあえず理由があります。
１つ目
隣にファミリーが来ました。
こればかりはねどうしようもなかった。
僕は今までですね、
この家も前の家もですね、今まで隣に人がいなくて、
かつ、角部屋だったので、
ぶっちゃけ声を出しても、誰にも迷惑はかかんなかったんですよ。
けど、なんと、なんとですね
今隣の部屋に家族が来てて
なかなか、動画自体が撮れない状況にあります。
別に普通に生活してたら全然いけると思うんですけど、
僕の場合、声出したり、なんかばくち…
爆竹は投げないぞ
大きい声出したり、物音とかたてたりちゃうんで、
僕は、ちょっと人に迷惑をまでかけて動画を撮りたくないなと思ってるんで、
服がしわしわだ。
まぁ、これがまず、引越しするための理由１つです。
隣に家族が来たので、迷惑をかけたくないので引っ越す。
もう１つ
とても…遠いんです。
いろんな人が僕んちに勝手に来たりするんで、
それを防止するために、超山奥にきたんですけど、
山奥に来たのは良かった。
人も来なくなった。
そして来なくなったみなさん、ありがとう。
だったんだけども、
実は、ここから僕の学校行くのに３０分以上かかるんですよ。
往復すると約１時間かかるんで、
それを１ケ月使うと、３０時間のタイムロスになる。
バイクで移動するから、バイクに乗ってる時何も出来ないんすよ。
フルに３０時間時間のロスがおきる。
＜ﾋﾟｰﾝﾎﾟｰﾝ
お、手伝ってくれる人が来ました。
えーとですね、何が言いたいかと言うと、
隣に家族が来た事ね、
家族来た事と、
遠い、全てにおいて遠い。
時間はな、お金に変えれないんだぞ？
で、あとねあれだ、コンビニが無い。
辛いっすねー
はじめ)そう
あの、近くにお店が無いんですよ。
最寄りのコンビニ、１キロ以上先にあるんで
本当に、生活するのが、やっとかっと(？)なんです。
引っ越す前に分かれば一番良かったんですけども、
引越ししてからじゃないと、分からない事もあったんで、
まぁ、今回は仕方ないかなと思っております。
約２ヵ月か。
約2ヵ月間、お世話になりましたぁーーーーー！！
じゃ、引っ越します。
おあぁあぁあぁあぁあ！！
びっくりしたぁ
マンピクテロ(？)こえぇえー
ヤバイよ。
あ
うぅ、うわぁ…爆竹入ってた。
とても静かでいい所でした。
ただ、
駅と学校が遠いってのもあったし、
今度こそ、ちゃんとこう、落ち着いて生活できるように、
頑張っていきたいと思います。
あれしよう。
あの、ジャンプで新しい部屋に行くやつ
せーの
はい。やってきました。
ここが新居でございます。
今回の部屋はレオパレスじゃないので、
家具を全部買わないといけないです。
ここにあるライトとかさぁ、
ここにある机とかさぁ、
エアコンとかも、ガスとかも、
あと冷蔵庫も今ないし、
実はまだ何もないんです。
引越しもねぇ、まぁ、楽じゃないんすよ。
引っ越し業者とか使ってないんで、お金はそんなかかってないんですけど、
取り敢えず今はインターネット使いたいのと、
冷蔵庫が無い。電子レンジも無い。
エアコンもない。
そう、ちょっとまだね、ほんとにね、
何にもないんで、
まぁ、徐々に整えていきつつ、
ここでちゃんと生活していこうと思います。
ついに始まったぜぇ。
2015年のはじめしゃちょーだー